bonjour bernard debré bonjour on va
commencer cette séquence par deux images
la première c'est cette vitrine de
librairies qui a beaucoup circulé sur
twitter sur les réseaux sociaux
on y retrouve les livres de nicolas
sarkozy alain juppé françois jean
françois copé et françois fillon
agrémenté vous savez de ses petits
commentaires facétieux parfois que
mettre les libraires dans les librairies
ces messages j'ai changé moi aussi moi
encore plus voilà qu'est ce que ça
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire cet
hommage d'humour lui mauvais français au
mois sa meneuse je ne me gêne pas et
c'est ça veut dire que les politiques
sont pris à leur propre piège parce que
je me souviens de jean françois copé le
juge aurait jamais la langue de bois
après il faut essayer après il faisait
bon vivre l'élection prés leur propre
c'est le jeu le jeu la seconde séquence
elle a été tournée par les caméras du
petit journal de canal + ce week-end
lors du conseil national des
républicains
elle met en scène brice hortefeux et
jean françois copé vous allez le voir
l'ambiance est assez glaciale regardez
jean françois copé est juste là chatel
et hortefeux approches vont ils saluent
écopé réponse
m
ambiance glaciale donc au vu de ces deux
documents est ce qu'il faut pas
s'inquiéter un peu de l'image que peut
vous renvoyer les républicains dans
cette période très présidentiel rachida
dati elle dit quelque chose elle dit la
primaire ça rend le parti complètement
fou est ce que vous êtes d'accord
comme toujours elle a raison
comme churchill qui dit l'est de la
république la démocratie pardon c'est ce
qui est pire sauf qui a rien d'autre
mais ben oui la primaire est
indispensable mais c'est sage ça rend un
peu sur les lecteurs qu'ils renvoient ou
un vis à vis de votre parti auprès des
électeurs est ce que c'est une bonne une
bonne image
non mais est ce qu'on peut faire autre
chose n'oubliez pas simplement que ces
élections de 2017 vont être très
particulière le deuxième tour va voir
s'affronter marine le pen contre soi la
droite soit la gauche ce n'est plus une
bataille droite gauche au deuxième tour
entre eux
le représentant du parti socialiste et
leurs bras entendez des menus party les
républicains c'est plus sain il faut
maintenant avoir un candidat dès le
premier tour qui rassemble qui rassemble
avec le centre la droite pour aller
combattre le front national au deuxième
tour
donc les primaires sont fondamentales
dispensable indispensable le candidat
dans ce dispositif que vous soutenez il
ya pas mais c'est pas un grand secret
six et ils s'ajustent françois fillon
oui je peins grand secret mais pourquoi
voulez-vous que j'ai un secret non c'est
ce que la vérité
il ya quelques semaines vous disiez de
lui vous êtes un soutien un peu critique
comme un ou deux il faudrait qu'il soit
un peu plus kubina ce qui lie un peu
plus au combat pour ce pour ce pour se
démarquer
est ce que par exemple cette semaine il
aurait dû être plus offensif comme vous
l'avait été il ya quelques minutes après
la mise en examen de nicolas sarkozy par
exemple réclamé que nicolas sarkozy se
met en retrait de pieds plus que l'amour
elle de dire qu'à lui voilà donc on sait
que les candidats sur ces munitions la
rondeur
il faut qu'il garde cette rondeur moi je
vais vous a besoin de la voir comment
expliquez vous que ça fonctionne aux
côtés
chef d'entreprise par exemple que son
programme visiblement un prime de ce
côté là mais que dans les sondages ces
radios karam boude et il est pas encore
le premier sondage tant s'en faut mais
moi je suis derrière lui parce que il
est honnête il est un bon programme et
j'ai ce qu'on appelle une certaine
fidélité c'est rare en politique et donc
je garde cette fidélité
je vais faire tout ce que je peux pour
l'aider avec d'autres il a beaucoup de
députés et sénateurs
je peins à l'opinion ça ne fonctionne
pas on verra on and on a quelques mois
vous pensez qu'il peut gagner
je l'espère je vais vous dire oui va
gagner va gagner mais bon je veux dire
je l'espère on va tout faire pour ça
c'est à dire que je vais aller avec
d'autres dans les villes de france je
vais en gironde je vais défendre
l'armure par exemple il faudrait qu'ils
forment là vous avez le problème et on
l'a dit souvent les politiques font un
peu de théâtre fait on quand on sort
d'ici quand on aura vu l'émission durera
vous avez été formidables
alors ça vous a plu ce que j'ai dit
hachez pas retenu mais votre cravate
était très très bien donc c'est ça qui
manque ce qu il faut la faconde les
gestes
il faut qu'on sente qu'il aime les
électeurs mais des comme ça françois
fillon parce que nous il est comme ça
mais timide il est timide c'est vrai que
dans la vie publique les timides en
force qu'ils n'attaquent force un peu ce
match il y en a un autre comme vous qui
ne porte pas vraiment nicolas sarkozy
agents son coeur c'est votre frère jean
louis debré il est libéré en quelques
jours de ses fonctions lundi de
président du conseil constitutionnel
il prépare apparemment un livre qui
devrait sortir au mois d'avril dans
lequel il reviendra sur son expérience
et notamment peut-être sur les pressions
qu'il a subies
du en provenance du camp de sarkozy
notamment au moment de la validation
vous en parlais tout à l'heure des
comptes de campagne de nicolas sarkozy
ça peut être une bombe pour pour nick et
assez il faudrait lui demander avec le
jeu maintenant on va écouter et il ya la
nécessité d'abord de ne rien dire tant
qu on est évidemment à ferrer ont libéré
peut-être pas non plus tout dire
pourquoi parce que quand même quand on
est
à sa place des choses qui ne doivent pas
être dit il est donné il est donc à
l'état d'esprit jolie d'objets sérielle
de mon ennemi c'est un petit conseil que
vous donnez ne dit pas tout est dit il
faut pas non plus se venger d'accord pas
de vendetta
jimmy grâce à une petite minute vers
guizhou et votre frère vous êtes aussi
très proche de jacques chirac est ce que
vous l'avez vu récemment est-ce que vous
avez des nouvelles à nous donner
non on est jugé d'abord pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que je les ai pas
vus récemment deux aimants qui a le
secret médical donc je ne dirai rien sur
jacques chirac
on sait tous qu'il va pas bien c'est
beaucoup et merci